η κυπριακή οικονομία πρέπει να μαστε ευχαριστημένι ότι ιπολύ καλή προπτική και νέ η πραγματική
οικονομία υποφέρει δηλαδή ο μέσως πολί της αλλά και μέση επιχείρηση γιατί όλι λέμε ότι
χωρίς πισικό έριο δεν μπορεί να γίνει η μείωση του ηλεκτρικού κόστος ου είναι βελάστικός
τος για όλους η ευρώ οποι έχει χάσει της συνογίτης όπως έχει χάσει και στους
κλίμα και σανταγωνιστικότητας και κοινοτομίας τη στιγμή ο εοτομίας είναι σε ένα προβληματικό στάδιο θα
τα αποκατούσα σε ότι αφορά που πάμε τα επογούμενα χρόνια ένα κράτος πρέπει να καθορίζει
που θέλω να πάει αυτός οτομας ένα πτυχή όπου σχεδιάζεται σήμερα μπορεί σε πέντετι κα
χρόνια να μην έχει ουσία και σηγμασία για την αγορά εργασία αρά ανδενεί ε είνεργός
και να επιμορφώνε στη συνεχώς σε κτός ίσα εκτός παινικίαλες και τή ίπαεετώ άλλον αντεέναλλά
ευπότκα σήμερα μαζί σας και εδώ στο στούτιο για ακοςχαςγιάνης ικονομικός αναλητήσ και σιότησία για
να δούμε ετά της οικονομίας κάι διαφορδικό σήμερα που αρκετή σιζη γίνε τελευταακόστετρρα γύρω από
την οικονομία την πράσην η φορολογία και τη και όχ μόνο για σε ευχαριστόπησε σήμερα
μαζί με καθώς σας βρήκα ευχαριστεκί προς κληση να πού με αρχικά ότι τη μέρα
που γυρίζουμε αυτό το επισόδιο του πότας είναι σε εξέλειξη ένα σε σαβικά πολέμος ανακοινόσεων
κυβέρνησης και αντιπολίτευσης γύρω από την εφτόχια την πράσινη φορολογία και όχι μόνο βάλαμε μια
άλλο από το διοχίαεκάρια ηόχι ι θα λέγα όχι γεννικά σαλλαώς δεν μαθαίνουμε και πολύ
εύκολα ξεχνάμεα δυστυχώς το δρια δεκατρία δεν είναι πριν εκατό χρόνια μολις πέρασε μια δεκαϊτία
βεβαίως είμαστε σε μια άλλη φάσει όσομ αφαρά την οικονομία αυτή τη στιγμή θα ελέγα
ότι σίγουρα αντι κάποιος οικονομικός ανς